[Music]
this holiday season families are seeing
lower prices on everyday items from gas
to groceries since 2019 that'd be just
before the pandemic the price of
Thanksgiving dinner has shot up
25% in fact as a share of earnings this
Thanksgiving dinner was the fourth
cheapest ever on record I want you all
know
that at the grocery store shoppers
continue to Grapple with stubborn
inflation canned cranberries cost 60%
more canned pumpkin prices have spiked
30% and russet potatoes are up
14% how you doing people I'm Dave Rubin
this is the rubben report it's November
29th 2023 we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals if you want to join
us for the post game show share your
comments ask me questions poke fun at
the fine gentleman in this room it's
Ruben report. locals.com before I get to
uh the top of the show today I just want
to say something really really nice just
happened about 20 minutes ago uh before
I got into the studio today we are you
know we're in our new studio that we've
been in since September and the studio
that I've been in since we moved to
Florida now it's almost two years ago
two years ago in two weeks which which
is just crazy uh we were in we were
upstairs in my house in what was a movie
theater previously in this house so it
was a totally soundproof room with no
windows or anything and we just used a
digital screen behind me of my old set
that we had back in Los Angeles and the
Hope was that when we had enough time
and obviously with kids and everything
else we just we would eventually build
out this proper Studio which we now have
done anyway we're right now in the
process of converting it back to a movie
theater and there's a tech guy upstairs
uh who we brought in to do some wiring
and some lighting and things and I went
upstairs just to say hi to him see how
the work's going uh and he came up to me
and he said Dave I just want you to know
I'm such a big fan of yours and I know
this is going to sound crazy uh but I
moved to Florida because of you I used
to live in Los Angeles just like you did
and I moved I moved my business and now
I'm thriving out here and I'm so happy
and then he busted out his phone and he
showed me an email that he sent me about
a year and a half ago which I don't even
know that I ever saw a lot of things
just get lost in the shuffle when it
comes to emails and that sort of thing
uh I'm sure my assistant saw it um but
showed me an email where he was like
Dave I think I'm going to move because
you move and I I hope I can go to
Florida and I'm going to have to it's
going to be tough but I'm going to make
it work and blah blah and now he's just
thriving and he's thrilled to be helping
us out with all this stuff and I was
immediately like well I got 20 other
projects for you and anyway I thought
that would be a nice little way to start
the day today because yes if you take
some autonomy uh over over your life and
you make some decisions for yourself you
actually can not just survive but thrive
in this crazy world uh one of the best
ways to thrive and this will get us to
our theme of the show today is to not
give too much power to the government so
you may remember our cold open yesterday
was uh our education secretary Miguel
Cardona completely 18 180
reverse misquoting Ronald Reagan with
his famous quote about eight words the
eight scariest words in the English
language right uh we're going to show
you the full clip and some other things
but the theme today is really going to
be about that that every time the
government gets involved in anything
they screw it up there are almost no
examples at least in the last 50 years
of the government doing anything and
making things better whether it's at the
federal level when it comes to our
immigration whether it's at the local
level when it comes to our blue cities
or whether it's at the cultur Al level
and everything else you guys get it
that's what we're doing today so let's
just dive right into it so first off
here is Secretary of Education Lord help
us all Miguel Cardona incorrectly
quoting Ronald Reagan you know we're
going to set up follow-up calls with
every Governor we met with to make sure
we're available um as uh I think it was
President Reagan said we're from the
government we're here to help um there's
there are resources there there's
technical assistance there and there's a
Playbook that could support the work
you're doing count on us as a partner in
this our students are waiting thank you
oh Miguel Miguel Miguel he kind of did
say that but he said it was the scariest
thing that they could say our fun little
meme makers here at the Ruben report put
this together um as uh I think it was
President Reagan said we're from the
government we're here to help surely you
can't be serious I think you all know
that I've always felt the
nine most terrifying words in the
English language are I'm from the
government and I'm here to
help do you see that there's a little
bit of a distinction between those two
things one is uh yeah we're here to help
this is great and one is it's literally
the scariest thing that can happen like
when the government shows up at your
door it's usually not a good thing what
is the government particularly good at I
do not know my friend Russell Brand over
on his show on Rumble uh he went off on
this sheer
Ridiculousness right now what Reagan
actually said as I recall was the most
terrifying words any American can hear
are I'm from the government I'm here to
help like you don't want the government
helping that's the opposite of the
meaning of the quote that's like saying
I remember Martin Luther King I Have a
Dream I dream that there's going to just
be race Wars all over the world no one
will ever get on they'll sit down at the
table of Brotherhood and have a massive
black people versus white people fight
that's the dream anyway or Winston
Churchill saying we will surrender on
the beaches we will capitulate on the
air strips We're going to lie down and
take this you better find your inner
Martin Luther King you better find your
inner Churchill cuz let me tell you
who's not going to help evoke that
Spirit The globalist Establishment that
watchs you dumb and distracted and to
misremember
quotes yes Russell that is correct I
will send you a text after to give you a
thumbs up um not only is that correct
but it's actually uh the reverse of what
the government is doing today because
this government right now thinks that
they can help you with everything and
they seem to be mucking up absolutely
everything and of course we can connect
that directly to the elderly man
pretending to be President Joe Biden
here's just a little compilation of Joe
often telling you how much he and the
government are going to help you let me
be the clearest on this point help is on
the way help is here we're here to help
all the people of this country help is
here help is here help is here let me be
clearest on this point help is on the
way we can get you help now we can get
you help now help is here and more help
is on the way and more help is needed
help is on the way help is on the way
help is on the way
help is on the way and I guess it's
becoming an overused phrase that help
was on the way help help help help help
help help help help help help help help
help help help help is here Lord help us
all that's basically where we're at at
this point but you get the
fundamental um disagreement here there
is a set of people that think that the
government is supposed to exist to help
you that this giant structure that you
fund will just help the people it will
take from some give to other it'll order
things correctly and do the right things
for the people I tend to think and I
think most of you think this that
especially if we were only to look at
the last three years very post Ronald
Reagan let's say if you were to look at
the last three years of what happened
during covid was the government out
there to help you when the government
locked you in your house and the
government didn't let you go to work and
the government forced you to be injected
with things and all of the other stuff
were they helping you were they looking
out for your best interests do you think
the CDC or the NIH or Joe Biden or the
people who demand more of your tax money
as they litter it away on nonsensical
gender programs and everything else are
they really there to help you or is the
is what Ronald Reagan actually said the
correct thing that the nine scariest
words in the English language are I'm
from the government I'm here to help if
someone from the government showed up at
your house today would you consider that
a good thing or a bad thing most likely
it would be a bad thing like what would
I'm even really like what would be the
good if the government showed up at your
house the government knocked on the door
of your apartment what would be a good
Phoenix there's a there's a chemical
spill we're here to carry you out and
bring that that might be one what else
could it be the the aliens have invaded
we're here to take you to safety which
most likely like that's not going to
work either like there's the point is
they muck up everything because the
government has become just this giant
sucking machine it sucks money it sucks
it sucks the human mind right you think
the best and the brightest you're going
to work at the government right now it's
what I always say about when they want
you know the government government
Regulators to regulate Google and
everything else now I think there's
reasons that these companies have uh
gotten too big and that there's perhaps
something we can do about it maybe with
antitrust or something but the idea that
a imagine a government regulator a guy
puts on his you know plastic hat and he
walks into the Google office and I'm
from the government and I'm here to look
at the algorithm and then they walk him
into the room and I don't know what it
is it's a big glowing laser or whatever
the hell the algorithm is at this point
you get it like he's like oh look at you
I'm going to fix that I'm a government
regulator making $62,000 a year you guys
get it so this is going to be the theme
throughout the show cuz we're just going
to show you how they have systematically
destroyed cities states and how they are
trying to destroy this country and yes
this is now happening all over the world
so instead of lecturing you on political
philosophy today I don't want to lecture
you today I'm just going to Simply show
you why it's dangerous to re rely on the
government and why it's dangerous to
elect leaders who think it's their duty
to be your dad you have a dad or you
might have had a dad or you got somebody
that cares about you more than the
government I promise you that so that's
what we're doing today let me talk to
you about my Patriot Supply guys it's
clear the unthinkable is here our most
trusted institutions now deceive us
every single day something's clearly
wrong and it's time time is short to
become more self-reliant and secure for
the future of your family act today with
my Patriot Supply my Patriot Supply is
the country's largest preparedness
company and they're more than equipped
to stock your shelves their bestselling
three-month emergency food kit provides
delicious breakfasts and lunches and
dinners that lasts up to 70 uh 25 years
in storage these kits provide over 2
,000 calories every day and are simple
to prepare just add water and heat then
eat make sure every member of your
family has a 3month food kit from my
Patriot Supply go now to my special
website that's prepare withth ruben.com
order by 3 p.m. today and your food kit
ships fast on the same day with free
shipping it's best not it's best to have
emergency food and not need it than to
need it and not have it that's prepare
withth ruben.com prepare withth
ruben.com and now back to me this whole
episode this whole show is going to show
you why you need to prepare with
ruben.com I want to show you a tweet
from uh Senator Mike Lee from Utah now
Senator Mike Lee he's largely a
Libertarian I've had him on the show a
couple times uh he he is a nice guy and
he is a patriot and he cares deeply
about America he retweeted Tom Cotton so
let me read you the Tom Cotton tweet
first he wrote Tom Cotton wrote in the
spring of
1945 we did much much worse in Dresden
and Tokyo than anything Israel has done
in Gaza and it was justified the Biden
Administration is in overdrive to
pressure Israel not to take the steps
necessary to deal with the existential
Terror threat from Hamas uh Mike Ley
then retweeted that and wrote we're
lucky Biden wasn't our president during
World War II now the way I'm linking
that to what I started with today of
course is that they tell you that
they're from the government and they're
here to help but it seems to me that
every time our government gets involved
in anything and I think you can
definitely connect this to what's
happening with Israel and Hamas right
now where we're doing this strange
equivocation of the two sides we're
clearly putting on pressure on Israel
not to topple Hamas uh I think people
are starting to see through that
sometimes you do have to win a war right
I'm not calling for American troops to
be in the Middle East I'm calling for uh
diplomatic support we can have some
military support if needed right I mean
there are agreements that are already in
place related to all of that uh but the
government the more it gets involved
seems to just screw everything up so now
I want to show you what's going on in
Oakland right now this is abolutely wild
the Oakland City Council Oakland
California uh voted for a resolution to
call for a
ceasefire uh between Israel and Hamas I
don't know what the people of Oakland
think that the government is for or that
they have any right to be telling
another Nation what to do or do they
have any of their own problems in
Oakland or anything else but anyway they
voted
80 to demand that Israel now they're
they they're roughly I don't know it's
got to be 8,000 miles away from Israel
but the people of Oakland voted or the
city counil of Oakland voted
80 to call for a ceasefire one city
council member then tried to insert
language in it at least to just condemn
Hamas that she knew that it was not
going to happen that you know they were
going to actually not vote for this
thing but they tried to at least put a
little language in there just condemning
Hamas now I want to show you this about
45 seconds or so of the reaction of some
of the Oakland citizens when all they
wanted to put into the thing they were
going to call for a ceasefire no matter
what was just a little mild condemnation
of the terror group Hamas enjoy there's
not been beheadings of babies and
rapings Israel murdered their own people
on October 7th calling Hamas a terrorist
organization is ridiculous racist and
plays into genocidal propaganda that is
flooding our media and that we should be
doing everything possible to combat I
support the right of Palestinians to
resist occupation including through
Hamas the armed wing of the unified
Palestinian resistance as an Arab asking
with this context to condemn Hamas is
very anti-arab racist the notion that
this was a massacre of Jews is a
fabricated narrative many of those
killed on October 7th ma'am your time is
up including children were killed by the
IDF an amendment condemning Hamas is
bald propaganda meant to have thank you
your time is up to hear them complain
about Hamas violence is like listening
to a wife beater complain when his wife
finally stands up and fights back
question did anyone else notice that
those who oppose this resolution are old
white supremacists there's been a lot of
atrocity propaganda raging from claims
of beheaded babies to mass rape Hamas is
not a terrorist organization just
because the US and Israel um deems it so
Hamas is a resistance organization that
is fighting for the liberation of
Palestinian people in their land okay I
don't think we need to parse through all
the ridiculous things that those people
said and and it's another example how
Tik Tock and algorithms have broken
people's brains and our education system
has absolutely failed young people and
the how radical the base of the Democrat
Party has got but again I want to
connect this to where we started I'm
from the government I'm here to help the
Oakland government which has plenty of
problems in Oakland we're about to get
to that decides to vote waste a moment
waste one second of the day on a
nonsensical vote having nothing to do
with anything relative to the to the
lives of the people of Oakland then one
person tries to say something roughly
saying I don't know Hamas not great
people and then these clowns get up
there this is a giant waste of time it
is a waste of money and now let's go to
things that are actually happening in
Oakland right now here's a tweet from a
Hollywood actor I don't know that he's
considered an actor anymore because I
don't think he can work anymore because
he's a conservative but Hollywood actor
James Woods posted this yesterday uh
here's Oakland FYI and this is similar
to what's happening of course in San
Francisco in La I mean look at that that
is America that is a once great city of
Oakland uh but we've got more here is
video of a massive homeless camp that
went on fire and is burning the 880
Freeway in Oakland
California holy y'all okay so I'm going
to drive through the fire
Jesus
holy the whole bridge is on
fire holy
sh I'm
scared I mean do we keep
driving no you don't keep driving what
are you doing I get it everyone wants
clicks do I drive into the abyss like
wait are we live streaming this because
if I have to post it after I'm dead
that's going to be a problem anyway you
might remember that what was it about
three weeks ago the 10 freeway which is
a huge freeway in Los Angeles also was
burning because of an LA homeless
encampment underneath the freeway it is
still closed now so la homeless
encampments burning roads closed Oakland
same exact thing um here's some other
stuff happening in Oakland this is just
over the
weekend
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't think that's
legal that would not fly in Miami you
know what I mean that would not fly in a
place where people believ that there was
Law and Order or that if you do
something illegal or if you steal $700
worth of stuff from a drugstore that you
might get in trouble you guys get all
that now I want to to show you a little
more more info again and I'm relating
this all to the nonsense that those
dingbats were doing in the Oakland that
they they're voting on on whether Israel
should defend itself from people
committed to their destruction meanwhile
this is what's happening in their uh in
their City this is info from the Oakland
PD this is a chart that shows criminal
incidences where people get violently
assaulted robbed or murdered and uh yeah
you don't have to be a scientician to
note that that is going up uh let me
read this from recall Pamela price
Pamela price is the Lefty of course
Progressive district attorney a shocker
a progressive district attorney
destroying a City crime in Oakland once
again Pam price demonstrates her job
Effectiveness the chart shows criminal
instances where people get violently
assaulted robbed murdered Etc data
doesn't lie Pam price uh and yes this
all exploded just a couple weeks after
she took office in January uh 2023 it is
also worth noting that the Oakland A
remember the Oakland A from back in my
baseball days what 1989 with Jose cono
and Mark Maguire was that 89 what year
was that World Series against the was it
89 I think it was 89 against the San
Francisco Giants Will Clark and uh
Mitchell was the center fielder I think
I think that was 89 with the year of the
the earthquake anyway the Oakland A's
baseball team they're leaving Oakland
this is just from a couple days ago they
are moving to Las Vegas Las Vegas OD a
place of Law and Order you don't really
think about that when you think about
Vegas but yes uh they are moving because
people cannot live in Oakland anymore
because they are Mo mostly focused on
whether the Jews 8,000 miles away are
going to defend themselves or not anyway
uh here's video uh back in
2021 Gavin Nome who was was and still is
the governor of California uh he was
attacked by a homeless man when he went
to Oakland GL I kind of dig this guy uh
and here's this video of the aftermath
of
that any ever J WIP straight up look
good in my head
so you know that guy had his Reasons I'm
sure but speaking of new Nome he is the
perfect example of what I am talking
about when I tell you that if you think
the government is here to help you your
head is on a little screwy let's say uh
I now want to show you video of 2008 I
think we've shown this once or twice
before over the years uh this is then
San Francisco mayor Gavin Nome
presenting his 10-year plan to end
homelessness now I don't have my
advocacy year but 10 years after 2008
that would be 2018 did that right off
the top of my head uh we are now in 2023
rolling into 24 I don't think this all
worked out but take a look for yourself
again 2008 We Believe fundamentally that
food solves hunger that shelters solve
sleep and that housing solves
homelessness and if we're going to solve
the problem uh of those that are out on
the streets that we Define as homeless
we better solve the housing problem if
we're going to have an impact and that's
why we established this framework what
we call a 10-year plan to end chronic
homeless in San Francisco you did not
end chronic homelessness in San
Francisco you DED you you you what's
give me a give me a word on this one you
you yeah you did not do that okay you
didn't do that um the very notion that a
lack of housing causes homelessness is
kind of insane now first off the market
usually allows for homes to be built
right when people start moving to a
place then home builders come then more
infrastructure gets put in it's not to
say like again here what do I always
tell you about Florida some of the the
struggles of Florida right now are due
to our success so many people have come
here that housing prices have gone up so
there is a scarcity of houses but now
what's happening we have tons of home
builders uh coming in right now I can
tell you with just where I live if you
were to take 10 square blocks there are
pro I kid you not there are probably 40
houses being built they're knocking down
things they're building new ones the
infrastructure projects the santis has
moved seven I think you told me it was
seven seven seven 20-year projects were
moved up to to be seven-year projects so
they were going to take 20 some odd
years to do for these infrastructure
projects roads things of that nature and
he made them all seven-year projects
because of success the idea that
homelessness is just because there isn't
enough housing is absolutely insane when
you see most of those people when we
show you those homeless encampments when
you see what's going on on San Francisco
streets and every else does it look like
those people are just struggling because
they can't find a home because they
can't get into a house because they
can't rent a condo or is it because of
drugs is it because of mental health is
it because of economic conditions that
the Democrats lead so that people can't
get decent jobs and then they're
frustrated with their lives and then
they turn to drugs and other things of
that nature uh but here's some data from
Stanford's Institute for economic policy
research San Francisco you love this one
guys uh they built no new shelters
during their 10-year period plan so that
was the 10 years look at this the 10
years following Gavin Newsome's 10-year
plan they built none and then what
happened they started building shelters
and homelessness went up how about that
uh we've got some California state
homeless point in time counts in 2004
there were
140,000 homeless in Cali 2014 there were
2018 uh with Nome now as Governor 130
and as of last year 2022 they're
160,000 plus uh what's also interesting
so what you're seeing of course on that
chart is C is the red one so you can see
it's just exploding under Nome and going
up you see that kind of is it greenish
one kind of right there the third one
from the top that's Florida Florida's on
the way down how bizarre how bizarre a
state with no income tax a state that
welcome people to come here and then
figure out how they want to live and not
give them a crazy amount of Regulation
when they open up a new business and
create the conditions for people to
thrive homelessness goes down so it has
nothing to do with the amount of homes
but nuum has been lying and gaslighting
people on this forever right because
he's from the government and he's here
to help but when he says help he means
destroy he means he will become super
rich he's worth the about 50 million
bucks didn't close his Winery in Napa
during Co when he closed everybody
else's uh but he's been he just lies
about everything and he does it really
slickly he's a great liar I I will give
him credit where credit is due uh here
he is you may remember this one uh this
is about two months ago explaining why
uh there are no businesses left in San
Francisco you see what's happening there
we do see businesses moving out for
various reasons but some of them saying
they're concerned about the crime in the
area when you see that happening to your
beloved City what goes through your mind
and do you think something's going wrong
there no I think they're they're
struggling to recover from the pandemic
they're struggling uh to come back
they're struggling with the the the
macroeconomic shifts particularly as it
relates to uh telor as it relates to
what's the future of a downtown is it
stacking of offices or stacking of
people and they're in the process of
rezoning and rebirth and reimagination
by the way I've seen that in San
Francisco for decades yeah it's just
words it's just words and I get it dude
your suit fits well the slime in your
hair is good I get it the work on your
teeth you've done it all right right and
and I get that they'll probably figure
out a way to get old bones out of the
way and make you the nominee and all of
that stuff but it's all just meaningless
right oh it's postco whatever why aren't
we having that here why is that
everywhere you go in Florida and I look
I'm in Miami which is obviously one of
the most thriving cities in the entire
world or certainly the most thriving in
America right now but you can go
virtually anywhere in Florida and there
are stores opening everywhere there are
people moving everywhere roads being
built everywhere do we not have the same
macroeconomic Trends do we not have the
same uh postco hangover well actually we
don't because Florida treated covid a
bit differently uh anyway there was a
very very popular Whole Foods now Whole
Foods when a Whole Foods moves into your
neighborhood you know things are going
well right Whole Foods was used to be
like an elite elite Supermarket then
Amazon purchased it but it's still
considered on the high end they used to
the joke about Whole Foods was it was
whole paycheck Foods because it's not
cheap so it's like if Whole Foods moves
into your neighborhood it's like a
Starbucks moving in it shows that oh
there's things happening now
unfortunately a certain set of people
call that gentrification and they don't
want nice things moving into their
neighborhood uh but one of the most
popular Whole Foods in all of San
Francisco uh just closed and uh well
Newsome had a thought on that too all
foods did shut down one business but
there was a bad location to begin with
they're opening a new one we have 2.7
sister was out here recently with her
team and I said don't go to the warf
certain parts are bad and we own that I
just put the National Guard and the CHP
down there and it's just Band-Aid over
with this guy it never stops
they close they're going to open another
one you have again go to the warf well
don't go to the WARF in San Francisco go
anywhere else go to Miami Beach like go
anywhere else don't go to those places
and and by the way people are not and
baseball teams are leaving his State and
everything else um here he is let's
we're just on a roll we're on a Gavin
Nome Roll by by the way tomorrow it's
tomorrow right Gavin Newsome will be
debating Ronda santis uh which we will
cover obviously on Friday here's Gavin
Newsome in
2007 uh blaming the violent assault of a
Yale singing group on underage drinking
um uh so I'm asking about the attack on
the Yale students over new years's and
you know it's kind of spreading across
the country a couple of some news
outlets and other countries are picking
it up uh and it's a good reminder how
important it is to remind uh our parents
to be good stewards of of underage
drinking I appreciate that the only
other question I have is hasn't been a
very uh easy week for you and I wonder
whether you have any comment on the
materan Ross story about the
drinking thank you very much that was a
great sheat shot you can't help yourself
you
cannot just know for the record it's
it's increasingly impossible to have a
conversation May mayor was out there you
know you just so just know it's not
personal when I walk by it he just send
some other reporters it's going to be a
lot easier to all right what he's very
upset about there is the question was
related to his own drinking uh and uh a
few weeks after that uh well it was
first found out that he was drinking
with a 20-year-old girlfriend and a few
weeks after that he checked into rehab
or alcohol which he now denies right but
it's like fully out there you can Google
it yourself let's just do a little bit
more on good old gav Nome in April of
2020 uh as the country was falling apart
because of Co lockdowns and everything
else and Cali was like the epicenter of
all of that nonsense in America uh he
was mostly concerned with aid for
illegal immigrants who again are not
citizens don't pay taxes only take and
by very definition of them being here
are breaking law uh we feel a deep sense
of gratitude uh for people that are in
fear of deportation but are still
addressing the essential needs of tens
of millions of California cians and
that's why I'm proud as Governor to be
the first state to announce a program uh
for direct Disaster Assistance to those
individuals we're putting up $75 million
in partnership with philanthropy
philanthropy is matching our efforts not
dollar for dollar but they're putting in
additional $50 million to support our
efforts so a total of
$125 million to provide individual
assistance of $500 and households
assistance
up to
$1,000 for those individuals uh that are
quite literally uh putting themselves on
the line uh and helping support uh this
economy and those most in need at this
moment where did we start today I'm from
the government and I'm here to help we
have now laid out a case of how this
alcoholic lunatic and I would say uh
generally um psychotic like there's
something psychotic about this man he is
not something is not right with this guy
right we can all see through it he is
the bad guy in a Disney movie do you
ever see the Disney movie Robots you
guys remember the movie Robots from like
20 years ago he's the bad guy Greg caner
played a bad guy a bad guy robot in a
slick suit if you haven't seen the well
I don't want to watch it anyone watch a
Disney movie probably probably transed
up now but
anyway you see what he was doing there
the government in the height of covid
right this is like two months into covid
all of the things that they had done to
destroy businesses and what was he
mostly concerned about that these
illegal immigrants get $500 for
individuals and a, for families it is
nice that I guess he has some of it from
private donors I guess that's kind of
nice so thank you that actually makes
the argument more so that individual
donors know what to do with their money
more than the government does uh but uh
here's another one with Newsome we are
on a Newsome Ro do I have to apologize
to for everybody to showing so many
Newsome quotes in one
show we have no view quotes we have no
view Clips today so that's pretty good
anyway here's Nome blaming Trump's
immigration policies for people fleeing
uh California which just don't
understand go are more people leaving
California for Texas or leaving Texas
for California well we lost about
182,000 folks in the last but how do you
explain that against the backdrop of
those very remarkable statistics you
just cited many factors and there's been
two deep analysis that drives the number
one factor the almost the the vast
majority almost the entire amount
impacted because of Visa policies and
the Trump Administration I mean our
formula for success is getting first
round draft choic around the rest of the
world I mean we're as dumb as we want to
be this whole damn border debate is made
up it's made up where's Congress where
the hell are they haven't done their job
the Border debate is made up he he is
American Psycho remember Christian Bale
and American Psycho that is that man I
don't want you to watch Robots at the
Disney movie go watch American Psycho or
read the book but you got to watch it
cuz cuz Bale looks just like him the
hair everything but anyway the smug way
the body language the border is made up
by the way it's almost a million people
since covid so it's now three years
roughly since covid we're almost into
the fourth year it's almost a million
people that have left California do
anyone watching this does anyone know
anyone who has moved to California I
literally met a man in my own house
today this morning who left
California that's odd or not odd because
the numbers bear it out um let's get a
little data from the migration policy
Institute you know how many unauthorized
AKA ilal immigrants there are in
California right now
2.8 million two really think about that
that is a small nation's worth of people
that are illegal in California right now
by the very nature of them being there
they are breaking the law they are then
taking from the people who produce the
taxpayer you if you're watching this in
Cali you go to work every day the
government comes in they take your money
the federal government comes in and
takes federal taxes the state government
takes income tax and you have payroll
tax and all of those other things and
then they give services to people who
aren't even supposed to be here in the
first place and then at the same time
you look at your roads and your roads
are crumbling your policing's not that
good there's drug use everywhere Etc it
could really drive you to use drugs I
suppose you know I really think it could
um anyway way here's uh Nome and then
later Joe Biden explaining that uh well
policies that have created the Border
crisis kind of have nothing to do with
that so let's just State the facts we
are currently experiencing the lowest
number of border crossings since
1971 in California like our nation our
undocumented population is at the lowest
level in more than a decade Mr Vice
President under the Trump Administration
Asylum has virtually ended ice detention
centers are empty uh your new plan calls
for reversing president Trump's harsh
plan but won't that restart a brand new
border crisis I mean what what would you
do with all those people in camps now
waiting in
Mexico it it will if we don't do it well
we don't reach out to the to the uh
communities that are willing to the
charitable communities that will come in
and help and and in addition to us
spending millions of dollars providing
for Access access for judges access for
Asylum folks to be on the boorder to
move it's just crazy words offered up by
Joe Biden and we all know I like the way
they made that Meme where you're seeing
the people roll in as he's just saying
words I should clarify that when when at
the beginning of that when we showed you
the the Newsome part that's 2019 and
he's like yeah we're doing all right at
the border who who is president in 2019
does anyone have a I don't have my
Abacus here I don't have my
thesaurus it was the orange guy yeah it
was the orange guy anyway are there
consequences when uh people like Joe
Biden and people like aome become
presidents and governors do you think
there are consequences to that um here's
Fox yesterday uh showing us a bit more
about what's happening at our
border this compared to the group that
you're seeing here as a steady stream of
migrants continue to head to Eagle Pass
this train was seen leaving Central
Mexico yesterday and is expected to
arrive in the city across from me this
week I want to bring in Lieutenant Chris
alz you brought us along last night we
saw that video of the train there do we
know when that train is expected to
arrive and what happens when it does
arrive to the city just across from us
well typically is what we see when we
see these type of Caravans the method of
transportation is usually trains so once
they make it to the northern part of
Mexico they'll get broken up into
smaller groups and then we'll see them
cross between the ports of Entry now we
do expect expect the train to arrive
very soon but of course we've been
seeing a constant flow here in Eagle
Pass with illegal immigrants Crossing
between ports of entry and when we talk
about the goway you talk about the sheer
number of people that are crossing well
the the the taxpayer the communities
here in Eagle Pass are having to
shoulder that burden and it's our
responsibility as a state to try to
prevent some of these legal Crossings
but as long as the federal government
continues to incentivize illegal
immigration we're going to see continue
seeing this flow of illegal immigration
between ports of ventry and also these
trains and kerans making their way to
the Border Stuart we have new numbers a
new report from the US House committee
on homeland security majority they say
the price tag per year is
$451
billion that is both for the housing and
care of the Asylum Seekers as well as
those known gods did you catch that did
you notice what was on that guy's
shoulder on his uniform there State
Police he's not supposed to be worrying
about the border the federal government
is supposed to be worrying about the
Border when Ronda santis says we're
going to send the Army down to the
border that sounds pretty freaking good
to me even Fox by the way Fox which is
actually covering this stuff right
they're not going to cover this on MSNBC
they're not going to cover it on CNN but
the way they casually cover it like oh
and there's a train going and there's a
whole bunch of people on that train and
they're on their way to the border and
it's just like like these things are
just supposed to happen a country is
supposed to be invaded and look at all
of these nice people and then of course
it always ends up for some bizar reason
all of the people fleeing the oppression
always appear to be sort of wellfed
decently dressed men in their 20s to 40s
I don't know where all the chicks are I
don't know where all the tired and the
poor and the huddled masses are where
it's old grandma with one suitcase
here's what's going on in the East
Village of New York City this is
literally yesterday illegal immigrants
online to get some of your
stuff
not one
chick that's weird not one old person
not one baby not one kid it's just all
dudes who kind of look like I don't know
maybe Hamas fighter age do we have any
freaking idea who is entering this
country and how stupid do you have to be
that sounds it's going to a little harsh
for me to say that sentence this way if
you still live in New York City and
you're seeing that in your neighborhood
East Village used to be cool and hip and
like funky and that's where comedy
standup comedy in America was born and
it's and like music and Bob Dylan Like
It was just such a great interesting
area the Lower East Side and now it's
like being overrun and and if you live
there and you are still allowing them to
take your dollars to do that like at
some point the rubber hits the road and
then you just kind of deserve what you
get and and what you're going to get is
not going to be good I hate to tell you
um but their cities burned and they
collapse and of course again these are
always Democrat run cities and and it
never failed so now I want to show you a
tweet by Alex Soros Alex Soros is the
son of George Soros and George Soros is
now like 187 years old so Alex is
running a lot of the uh Soros evil
operations uh from Cobra Mountain
somewhere uh he tweeted this uh article
out and it was where are murder rates
actually higher not in Progressive
cities he got community note fact
checked on that you guys know Community
notes is the factchecking apparatus that
Twitter now has which is why so many
people are angry at Twitter because they
can actually fact check in real time and
check this out Community notes the five
cities with the highest murder rate and
their Mayors
are St Louis Missouri Tora Jones
Democrat Baltimore Maryland Brandon
Scott Democrat New Orleans Louisiana
Latoya Cantrell Democrat Detroit
Michigan Mike Dugan Democrat Cleveland
Ohio Justin
bib
demat do you see a theme I think you do
now I want to show you a national
treasure you guys know Senator John
Kennedy from Louisiana there was a
hearing in the senate about shootings
death Chicago all they got all these
laws in Chicago don't shoot people here
we put up a sign it's a gun-free zone we
have this law it says don't do that why
do people keep doing these things how
many people were shot in Chicago we're
going to check the numbers while I show
you this video so we'll get the numbers
on Chicago shootings this past weekend
but here's John Kennedy asking uh Dr her
name is Dr Megan Ranny of the Yale
School of Public Health why it is that
Chicago has become just a crazy shooting
poooa let me ask you
this why do you
think that Chicago has
become America's largest
outdoor shooting
range do you think it's because
of Chicago
citizens uh who have no criminal
record but but who have a a LLY a gun in
their home for protection or perhaps for
hunting or do you think it's because of
a
finite group of criminals who
have wrap sheets as long as King Kong's
arm so Mississippi Louisiana and
Missouri actually have higher firearm
death rates um obviously there's certain
what about Chicago so I don't live in
Chicago it's not my primary area of
research you don't have an opinion on
that I think there's easy access to
Firearms compared with combined with
environmental conditions uh lack of
great education there have actually been
studies showing that when you green
vacant lots and repair abandoned
buildings in urban neighborhoods you see
decreases in gunshots in violence as
well as in stress and depression in the
neighborhoods around them no disrespect
doc but that sounds a lot like word
salad to
me he's just great he's just great like
she it's just nothing I'm a doctor I'm
an expert in nonsensical dribble never
everyone knows the people every freaking
weekend the people that are out shooting
people in Chicago they are not the
decent law abiding citizens of Chicago
we actually ran the numbers on Chicago
this weekend and it was a very Happy
Thanksgiving weekend over there because
only 14 people were shot Seven were
killed uh seven of those people who were
shot uh were teenagers and a 16-year-old
and a 12-year-old are dead but
relatively speaking to what's going on
in Chicago that's pretty good bizarre
that that's not going to make it on
MSNBC or CN now of course I don't even
have to look at the numbers it was
probably all black people shooting black
people doesn't help the narrative maybe
I'm wrong but I'm probably not and uh
well who does the mayor of Chicago blame
well wait we got another John Kennedy
no sorry oh sorry uh who does the mayor
of Chicago blame for the problems of a
Democrat run City for the last 80 years
where everyone's getting shot you're not
going to believe it and you are going to
believe it well it has to be better
coronation you know what we've seen is a
very raggedy form um instituted by
right-wing extremis extremism um
everyone knows that the right-wing
extremism in this country has targeted
democratically ran cities and quite
frankly uh they've been very intentional
about going after democratically ran
cities that are led by people of color
and their whole motivation is to create
disruption and Chaos because that's what
this that particular party has been
about right this is the same political
party that did not want to accept that
President Obama was actually an American
it's the same Republican right-wing
extremism that stormed the capital it's
the same right-wing extremism that
refuses to accept the results of the
Civil War it's raggedy it's
disrespectful it's mean-spirited it's an
unclean Spirit quite frankly and so so I
got you I got you I just want to make
sure that people understand what we're
facing that's why it's so important that
the faith community is leaning in In
This Moment guys guys guys guys
it's not the 80 years of democrat rule
in Chicago and Illinois it's not Lori
Lightfoot before him it's not this guy
it's not any of the economic conditions
or what they've done with homeless or
drugs or any of that stuff they have all
the laws by the way to stop people from
getting guns but people still get them
one way or another right because bad
people do bad things it's not any of
that it's that mean Republicans these
these freaking Republicans keep talking
about it why do they keep they are just
always focused on all of the black kids
that are shot here and
if if you want to see how stupid the
media is as it relates to all of this
this one just ramps the idiocy to a
entirely new level this is a tweet here
from uh the N wokeness account so dead
Spin and dead spin is just another one
of these sites now like Rolling Stone or
Vox or any any of these things they just
put out trash after trash after trash
check this out dead spin published a hit
piece on a little kid for wearing face
paint on his team of his team colors
they even used the camera angle to make
it look like he was wearing black face
so the kid's at a Chief's football game
and it looks like from the original
picture that you can see there on the
left that he's in full-on uh blackface
uh but of course no he's not in full-on
blackface he's in the traditional
Chief's colors half and half uh
apparently at the game this week now
thousands of people are going to put
their faes in that paint that that's
what I'm told that's what that's what I
heard to push back on this nonsense and
when I saw him in that uh color the
colors and and oh my God he's in black
face it reminded me of something from
back in the day remember this yeah
that's putty in Seinfeld who was going
to the the Devils game back in around 94
Devil's ho hockey game who's going to
win the
devil anyway the guy who wrote the
article that claimed that that kid who
was not in blackface was in blackface
he's a quote unquote journalist his name
is Karen J Phillips he tweeted out this
for the idiots in my mentions who are
treating this as some harmless act
because the other side of his face was
painted red I could make the argument
that makes it even worse y'all are the
ones who hate Mexicans but wear
sombreros on Cino I think he means Cino
Deo which is a great day to have a
margarita does that make me a
racist um you see these virtue signaling
fools I don't see any Mexican person out
there offended by the the red part what
are you saying the red part of his face
the Indian part of his face what are you
even saying but you know that this kid
is not racist the kid loves his freaking
football team but what they do is they
find racism everywhere that it isn't you
know where they never find racism where
it actually is so now I take you to the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC where Joy Reed and we have not
played a clip of Joy Reed in quite some
time I'm going to unbutton my jacket for
this Joy Reed so I'm ready to when I
when we come back um to give it my full
emotion here is Joy Reed interviewing a
Rutter's Professor so she must be very
learned Rutter's Professor um about how
Elon Musk is a Jew hater and so when we
see Elon Musk there and you're
scratching your head and saying but wait
a minute I thought that he was actually
you know has said very anti-semitic
things it's precisely because these are
not the same thing you can support
Israel and hate Jewish people and that's
and that's the the sad truth here is
that many of us who are fighting to free
Palestine are fighting for all people's
freedom including for Jewish
Liberation that woman's fighting for
Jewish Liberation by supporting
Palestine you can hate Jewish people but
support Israel these people does
somebody can we I want to send one of
you guys maybe we'll put you guys in a
costume we're send you over to them
MSNBC headquarters and I want you to
bring a uh I want you to just look
around and I want you to see right
before you know they get in the green
room they put their makeup on does
someone hit them with a frying pan right
before they get on camera like whack
them with a cast iron frying pan and
thus cause the brain damage that is on
that Network Elon Musk is not an
anti-semite if it wasn't for Elon Musk
opening up Twitter we would not have
seen the the hundreds of videos the
horrific videos that people in Oakland
pretend do not exist and the reason they
don't think they exist is because
they're being censored on other uh
social media Outlets but if if you're
still a little confused at this point as
to whether Elon Musk who just went to
Israel went to the kutzas that were
burned down saw the video the 47 minutes
of video including a woman who was
pregnant who they literally sliced her
stomach open and took the fetus out and
let her die out in front of her that is
literal he saw it for himself here is
Elon uh talking about Hamas and uh what
they did
I it was jarring to see the scene of the
massacre or one of the scenes of the
massacr um as well as to see the short
film
afterwards uh that uh showed a you know
more of of innocent people getting
killed I was troubling in that movie
especially to see the joy experienced by
the people that were killing innocent
civilians including kids and you know
babies and defenseless people
essentially
so um
you know it's it's one thing if
obviously if civilians die accidentally
um but if it's another thing to Revel in
the joy of killing civilians that's not
you know that's frankly that's evil yeah
that is evil and that's the guy they're
telling you is the number one
anti-semite that's the one that for the
last how many how many shows have I done
about Elon Musk in the last year plus
since he got Twitter which was right
around what was it about October last
year so he's had it for about 14 months
something like that how many episodes
have we done on this of the mainstream
media absolutely lying about him because
he's competition now how many shows have
we done about Joe Rogan because he's
competition now nobody in their right
mind thinks that Elon Musk is an
anti-semite you want to find some
anti-semites go to the New York Times
you want to find some anti-semites turn
on MSNBC say hi to Andrea Mitchell you
want to find some anti-semites go to
Oakland and listen to these people again
there's not been beheadings of babies
and rapings Israel murdered their own
people on October 7th calling Hamas a
terrorist organization is ridiculous
racist and plays into genocidal
propaganda that is flooding our media
and that we should be doing everything
possible to combat I support the right
of Palestinians to resist occupation
including through Hamas the armed wing
of the unified Palestinian resistance as
an Arab asking with this context to
condemn Hamas is very anti-arab racist
yeah you can find anti-semites you're
just have to look anywh who I'd like to
end today's program uh by talking about
what will happen to this country if we
do not become serious that was me
speaking a little more slowly like
Douglas Murray right there if we don't
start becoming a serious country if we
don't start defending our borders making
sure that the politicians like Miguel
Cardona the Secretary of Education who
lie to our faces are not just completely
removed making sure that I don't know
people with dementia aren't the
president of the United States States
making sure that evil Psychopaths like
Aban Nome are not the potential
successor to the guy with dementia all
of these things if we don't do this then
it will all just get worse and you might
look around and go ah America's pretty
screwy but guess what guys it could get
a hell of a lot worse because good
liberal wise pluralistic societies often
go down the tubes uh here's a little
something that I did with Denis Prager a
couple months back in Los Angeles I
worry about the future of the world I
worry about the nature of the world how
do you you've got a couple years on me
how do you where do you put where do you
put that in life it's just with you all
the time right this I knew at a very
early age the most cultured country in
the world built aitz there's this old
question how did the people who gave us
Beethoven and Bach give us aitz it's an
interesting question but it's it's
somewhat of a non seor why does having
bak and Beethoven inoculate you against
being becoming evil the ease with which
a civilization can turn morally that's
what Germany taught and I see that
happening in the United States the
German people and not all of them were
evil before the Nazis there were good
people that became evil
right the German people fell for the
belief that Adolf Hitler that the Nazi
party was going to help all of them and
save all of the save all of them and
stop all of their problems and if only
they could get rid of them then things
would be
better so when they tell you they from
the government and they're here to help
oh that they are not ladies and
gentlemen we will be live with people of
the internet I'm solo today Isabelle is
off to New Zealand for about a week uh
she's doing a speaking gig there so I am
solo just with you guys if you want to
get your questions in go to Ruben
report. locals.com I can talk to you
live reminder we have a new uh account
on Twitter Ruben report show where
that's where we're going to post all the
show clips my own personal Twitter will
be my thoughts and all that stuff and uh
we leave you with more from Biden
because we mostly hit Newsome on today's
show but here's a here's a little more
from Biden adios I keep telling
everybody ask why I pay so much
attention to the Latino Community
26 out of every 100 students in our
schools kindergarten through 12th grade
speak Spanish if we don't pay attention
we're crazy We're a nation and buil on
diversity and uh anyway but I have no
problem
[Music]